[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey happy holidays everybody episode 70
this is the Christmas special yeah it's
very special Christmas special
well we figured we'd would do the
Christmas special kind of this week
because you know the following Tuesday
is the day after Christmas right kind of
lame doing so yeah we don't have Boxing
Day here so I can't do a Boxing Day it's
not Christmas
it's not Christmas on the day that we're
recording this a matter of fact we just
saw Star Wars yeah the new Star Wars I
didn't like it I 80% Larry they like it
no there there was like one subplot that
I felt could have been excised there's
no reason to have the casino scene
that's what I mean
in the way they handle Snoke and then
the way they handle Skywalker nah just I
well you know it was not it was not in
character I'm gonna say that one thing I
really liked about it was that
everything I thought about was gonna
happen in this movie none of that [ __ ]
yeah none of it happened I liked that
because I liked that it was like I was
like oh it's going that way oh it's a
like he liked it showed that he wasn't
afraid to like taking it a different
direction cuz he knew people would be
pissy about it and that you know I was
like I admire that yeah but like I said
I 80% liked it other than that one
subplot I just felt like that could have
been taken out because it didn't really
amount to anything I thought I thought
it was a very beautiful well filmed
[ __ ] really it was kind of like
they took two movies and tried to wool
them leave them together ya know to me
they said it's kind of like because she
knows almost three hours long two and a
half two and a half two hours and 32
well these could have cut a half-hour
out of there and it was do it that's
what I mean they could have just taken
that one subplot out no I'm totally fine
but um you know overall I enjoyed it but
you know their work it had some problems
but you know I'm gonna kind of reserve
judgment on it until I see the third one
and I'm gonna see what where they're
gonna go with it yeah I mean what yeah
anybody can be a Jedi just you know it's
just all be Jedi's I don't know if
that's exactly what they were saying can
I be a wine on be a Jedi sure okay
[Music]
hey that's what you want yeah okay all
right so let's do our regular shout outs
the faceless villain my book the
audiobook is up right finally yeah we
got about codes yes so I haven't got the
I haven't got the free codes yet I
usually takes a few days they have to
email them to me but it's actually
available for purchase or available and
I think if you have like an audible
membership you might be able to get it
for free or get it for cheaper or
whatever but um so go on over there and
have a listen to that and you know if
you liked it leave me a review and all
that good stuff so I know some of you
were waiting for the audiobook and like
I said I haven't got the codes yet but
as soon as I get those I'll be seen you
begin you codes out yeah yeah it is
available now we just did a movie review
was the frighteners that was the last
one we did patreon normalling out yeah
patreon has gone back to normal yeah
they actually well they had never
enacted the fee increases they just said
they were going to everybody flipped out
and they said okay nevermind some of the
guys that left came back actually are uh
contributing more than they did before
that's yeah so you know we really
appreciate like you we actually ended up
only losing a couple of people and uh
you know some of the ones that stayed
like up their supports yeah they really
do appreciate you appreciate that we
know who you are yeah and you know and
and one person went to patreon also like
I said that's good - that's totally fine
so you know if you still want to know
they drop PayPal PayPal yeah yeah you
know I mean yeah but yeah so if you
still want to support the show you can
totally do that like I said if you still
want to don't want to use patreon that's
fine you can also go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast at wordpress.com
and there's a link in the sidebar for a
PayPal account oh also if you were a $20
up patron on patreon I mailed out some
free stuff a couple of days ago yeah
when I was going to England I think -
yeah so be on the lookout for that you
should be receiving it if you haven't
already autograph stuff yeah just you
know some free stuff I've had around and
it's kind of fun so you know look out
for that should be there very soon now
because it's the Christmas show and you
know we wanted to do a Christmas special
type of thing we'd actually talked about
doing this topic before yeah this is
actually a request yeah and it was kind
of a request and I thought well it seems
like a good time to do it yeah what I
around the Christmas season I guess yeah
we were doing another show and I
mentioned that revelations actually had
a lot to do with Roman astrology right
and somebody in the comment section says
hey man you want to do a show on that
can do a show on that and I had to go
back to the guy who was a master on this
subject his name is zoar he goes on his
youtube name or his YouTube channel name
his Zoroaster Zoroaster and the first
surah Zoroaster is spelled with an S
yeah and I came across this guy on dr.
Robert and prices Facebook group called
the Bible geek listeners face group
which is a private face Facebook group
that you have to that's called a face
group yeah you know I did call it a
facebook private Facebook group that you
have to ask to join and then they let
you in there and there's a lot of
scholarly types some in the mythology
and religion and you know they're from
across the board these guys are like
geeks into this kind of stuff I mean
they read scripture for fun you tell me
I mean yeah what they'll do is it's just
kind of like people that are super into
like the Marvel Cinematic users except
with biblical mythologies yeah and some
of these guys have doctorates in this
kind of stuff so they know what they're
talking about well I saw them going over
the work of Zoroaster Zoroaster who had
a bunch of YouTube videos and they were
asking each other hey is this check out
they were all proofreading and checking
his stuff and they were going yeah this
guy's for real he knows what he's
talking about and some of the Bible geek
members were also helping him helping
him in this research it's interesting
when you watch his video series on both
Daniel and his Daniel was easy he
thought Daniel was easy to the code but
if you watch him decoding from the very
beginning revelations he will go back
and correct mistakes that he made in
Prior videos so it's really fun to watch
a guy go through the entire thing and
then change his ideas as he goes based
on new information I think it's what
sixteen seventeen videos I think well
the revelation one his initial breakdown
I think was 25 minutes then he made like
an updated one that was for where he
just kind of summarized everything and
then the Daniel one is ten videos
through but they're not super long like
some of their between like three and
seven minutes right to watch watch them
all takes after about an hour from what
I remember an hour and a half and some
of it can get kind of intensive but he
does show you pictures of what it is
he's talking about in layouts of the
material but what what our show is gonna
do tonight is we're gonna basically kind
of do an overview and we're gonna
highlight a couple of things from that
we thought were injured we thought we
interesting from revelations possibly
Daniel yeah yeah I mean I thought the
revelation stuff was more interesting
the thing that I find cool about this
guy and I don't know if he's I mean
because the Daniel and revelation videos
he posted them in 2011 mm-hmm and I
don't know if he's I don't think he's
posted anything pertaining to that he's
posted a bunch of other stuff but I
don't think he's posted anything about
Daniel and revelation since then but the
interesting thing about him is that he's
not a theologian he's not I mean he has
a degree which I believe is in history
or Russian history I think his degree is
in but it's just something that he's
interested in but he admits that he was
kind of raised religious but he's
approaching this from an outsider point
of view he was like I wanted to kind of
approach it with a with a new eye and
try to just see what direction the text
would take me yeah because you know the
the evangelistic interpretation of
revelations is garbage okay yeah you
can't you can't take what they're sayin
that's why I used to see it back when I
was religious isn't when I was a kid but
that's not what the checks is talking
about we'll get into that and that's
what I thought was interesting about
this it seems like a lot of particularly
like you said evangelical
interpretations of daniel and revelation
kind of hinge on the fact that the stuff
in there is prophecy that it hasn't
happened yet yeah that's what they're
saying it is right but he's making the
argument and other Bible scholars make
this argument too that it's actually
kind of allegorical an allegorical story
about stuff that are already happened
right although he is saying the guy that
makes these videos there's a straight
guy he specifically says I don't think
that these people wrote these books to
like try and fool anybody or to like say
I can see the future blah blah blah but
he's like perhaps it was because maybe
they perceived time as cyclical you're
right and so they said well the past
will repeat itself in the future so you
know they're taking past events and
weaving an allegorical narrative about
them that they think will have an impact
on the future as well so it's it's
prophetic in that way but not in the
sense where they were psychic and they
knew what was going to happen and stuff
like that they're very clearly writing
about stuff that had already happened
yeah I don't totally agree with them on
that particular aspect I think what's
happened is as the person is writing
down the authors and yes they're not
one-off no definitely these books the
authors are talking about things that
already happened and that may lead to
the destruction of Rome in the case of
Revelations Wynne is wrong I'm gonna end
basically is what they said it'd be kind
of like a guy sitting in his house
watching the news and it's been watching
the news for 40 years writing down the
headlines going yeah and then there was
Ronald Reagan and the fire almost fell
from the sky and it was the end of the
world at any moment and then there was
George Bush and then you know then he
attacked this Saddam Hussein a little
bit and you know when is it gonna end
when is it gonna end over and over again
Jesus is coming any day that's basically
what they're yeah and and you have to
think too that I mean in the context of
the times you know these were Jewish
writers Christian writers the Roman
Empire was not coming to them and they
had no love for the Roman Empire so a
lot of the kind of villains in the story
and a lot of the stuff that they wrote
about were about their oppression by the
Romans right and so there is a lot of
that in there and one guy's got the book
and he's basically on watch he's taking
care of it and putting entries into the
book when he dies he passes it on to
another Christian who picks up the
mantle Thea nut I mean and he starts
writing things down and then he goes
back into the past and kind of touches
up certain things here or there yeah
which you know we'll talk about that
when the time comes they're trying to
foot tell the death of Rome and the
arrival of Jesus by writing down the
headlines basically of history yeah and
then looking back into history going
Scott it's got to be happening in any
minute and yes I definitely think that
that's kind of Dover and like I said you
know I have read there are a couple of
criticisms of some of this guy's stuff
but they seem fairly minor I don't like
I'm not a huge theology expert but I
mean most of the stuff that he says
sounds pretty reasonable and it checked
out with the Bible geeks and then yeah
and but when you talk about the Bible
geeks there's a couple hundred guys
there all of them of this different
disciplines yeah they couldn't find
thing wrong with that they said it rang
true and I think if I remember correctly
I think right I think dr. price came in
and go yeah it sound like he's got it
was something like that yeah so yeah so
like I said there I'm sure there's
things that he could be criticized about
or something cuz he's not you know he's
kind of an interested amateur yeah but
um yeah most of the stuff he said and
made a lot of sense yeah all the great
discoveries were done by interested
amateurs anyway hobby is the greatest
form of study well yeah because he's not
I mean he's not being paid to do that
that's not he was just something he was
interested in it was a project him and
these scriptures are not science these
scriptures are Scripture yeah it's kind
of like you know it's literature so do
you want to talk about revelation first
just talk about let's talk about let's
talk about revelation see okay so the
couple things that I wanted to talk
about the first thing we wanted to talk
about was the [ __ ] of Babylon
yeah and that kind of whole story yeah
more like an allegory yeah that whole
allegorical is that because that was the
part I mean like I said he breaks down
the whole book chapter by chapter but
most of the stuff that he's interested
in most of stuff that I'm interested as
the allegorical stuff like what did this
represent to this particular writer now
even though I think if this was one of
one of the criticisms that I read of his
stuff that I've seen a lot of biblical
scholars say you know the [ __ ] of
Babylon is obviously an allegory for
Rome yeah now some people have said no
it's Jerusalem and all this other stuff
but I don't know but on his videos he's
like I'm positing that it's wrong
because the [ __ ] of Babylon she's
riding on a beast that has seven heads
which he says represent the seven hills
of Rome yeah and all the horns represent
the Emperor's right and he's saying it
also represents seven Kings yeah and
then there's like another horn and then
there's ten horns which he's arguing
represent the roman emperors in order
yeah okay so the verse says you know the
seven kings there's five of them are
dead there aren't they've already gone
one of them is alive now at the
contemporary time it was written one is
yet to come and then there's an eighth
one who is kind of a controversial sort
of figure but we'll get into that a
minute so the first five that are dead
he argues our Julius Caesar Augustus
Tiberius Caligula and Claudius who were
the first five new emperors now the one
that's alive now the sixth King mm-hmm
that's nearer or alive in the time of
the writing alive at the time yeah a lot
of words contemporary yeah is Nero right
now Nero was a reviled figure among the
Jewish and Christian early writers
probably because he persecuted them
mercilessly and so let's have a story
well that's how the story goes yeah some
of questions that yeah so so he's saying
in Revelation the verse 16 referring to
fire and ruin and things like that he's
like that's probably referring to the
great fire which happened in 64c II
which some which rumors kind of came
after that Nero had started that row
even if he didn't start it like himself
like he hadn't started so because after
that part of the after it all burned
down he built some [ __ ] on top yeah big
palaces and stuff right is it sound like
a real estate grab right and also the
fact that after the fire was over in the
destruction it happened everything like
that that Nero was very quick to blame
the Christians for causing the fire and
therefore justifying his further
persecution of them so he so those are
the first six kings now he says the
seventh king is probably he's like this
word where it gets a little problematic
because after Nero committed suicide in
68 C II there was a there were three
different guys like vying to be Emperor
yeah and this was Vitellius Otho and
Galba he's like so I'm not sure if like
the seventh King refers to one of them
or whatever now this is in one of his
videos like actually the first one what
he did was he made the original series
that was 25 videos law talking about
revelation he made that and you can see
that he was kind of sort and step out he
said I'm just kind of going chapter by
chapter I'm not reading ahead or
anything like that so I'm just kind of
doing these as they go and then later on
he made like a summary set of videos or
only four videos where he kind of
clarified some of the stuff that was
kind of muddled in the first one because
in the first one he was like oh well
maybe the seventh king is just those
three emperors and then the eighth king
was supposed to be titus right know best
patient this patient who was the next
one because Vespasian's was the one that
took over after the three they weren't
really vying for power it's like one of
them was Emperor then another one was
Emperor and so it was just like happened
over this one year right but then like
the more he read about it and stuff like
that he's like okay well here's what
I've come to the conclusion he's like
because the eighth king is such a weird
they call the eighth king one who was
but now is not right and they have all
this stuff about because he's talking
about the relationship between
revelation 13 and revelation 17 and
there's the stuff about the two beasts
and everything like that and he's
arguing that the eighth king is actually
not a real person but that he's an
allegory for Nero returned through
someone else right like an emperor or a
king that is possessed by the evil
spirit of Nero right because he makes
the point he's like one Jews and
Christians were terrified of Nero you
know he had [ __ ] him up real good they
did not like him and he's like a lot of
them at the time did not believe that he
had really died and he's like for many
years afterward like Nero pretenders
would like show up here and there so he
was almost like this boogeyman run so
he's arguing that he's like whether this
was referring to an actual king or not
he's like I'm kind of arguing that the
8th king was not a real person per se
but was actually kind of like the
resurrected Nero or someone channeling
Nero okay and what he ends up arguing is
that there's this whole thing about like
I said he's making the relationship
between Revelation 13 and 17 about the
two beasts the beasts of the sea and the
beasts of the earth now the beasts of
the earth he makes a pretty good case
that the beasts of the earth refers to
Titus yeah now Titus believe was
Vespasian's son yeah now he was not and
I never at the time he became one later
he was a general but yeah he was a
general now Titus was the one
responsible for the siege of Jerusalem
right when it was a big deal when they
lost the temple yeah in 42 months all
the biblical references to 42 months
he's arguing are probably a reference to
that because that's about how long it
took so he's arguing that Titus was the
one like having Nero speak through him
right and there's also there's also a
reference to to the quote-unquote mark
of the beast which he argues is a coin
he's like because Jerusalem Judea they
had their own money right and they did
not want to come under the Roman system
come to come under the Roman system
which included the money which had a
picture of Nero on it right so if you
got involved with the with the Roman
money system you were basically taking
the number of the beast yes what they're
saying that's what he's arguing he's
like there could be he's like there is
some scholarship that says that the mark
of the beast could also refer to like
the Roman eagle standard like how some
people had to like bow to it or how they
would like touch it to their forehead or
something like that he's like I tend to
think it's just an economic reference
that it's just a coin that it
represented yeah because if you coming
under Roman rule which they didn't want
to if you didn't have the mark you
couldn't buy it you couldn't buy try to
sell so they didn't want to be absorbed
into the Roman economic system this is
what they're saying right and yeah and
that and he thinks that that's what
they're referring to so in this way he's
kind of thinking that Titus is the Beast
of the earth okay and that the Beast of
the sea is actually Nero so the Beast of
the earth is like or the Beast of the
sea is like speaking through the Beast
of the earth right because he said the
Bible specifically says I think it's
revelation 17 that says that the Beast
of the earth doesn't have any authority
of his own it has like borrowed a Thor's
given to it right so like I said Titus
was not an emperor at the time he became
one later but at the time he wasn't now
he's also arguing that the the other
horns that they're talking about were
future emperors you know this would clue
to include Titus Domitian Nerva Trajan
Hadrian Antoninus Pius Lucius verus
Marcus Aurelius and communists and he's
like maybe septimus severus he's like
but maybe not because that guy he's like
I kind of want the tenth one to be
Commodus because he was kind of the
Emperor that he was the last one before
the Empire started to decline and after
him you know it was another situation
like after Nero had died where there
were several people like vying for the
throne right so he's like so if the 8th
King is allegorical then the 10th King
becomes Commodus and that makes a lot
more sense so you know we have like a
weird situation where you have an author
who's telling you that one of the Kings
exists now yes but he knows the Kings
that are coming right that's that's kind
of weird because he's using allegory to
paint a picture of history but he's
telling you a history as if he's in the
past as if he's in the past which is
kind of strange and I guess that's some
of the guy I want would say I want to
really want to say trickery but part of
the art of giving you a prophecy writing
about the past that you already know and
putting yourself in the past when you
write it to make it look like that
prophecy got fulfilled yeah that's what
it looks like so it's the same thing and
like I said a lot of prophetic kind of
writers have done this where you kind of
mask things and layers of allegory and
stuff so one so it's vague enough that
it could kind of refer to anything
Nostradamus also did that but you know
making it taking stuff in the past and
dressing it up in like a fancy language
which seems to be what these people like
you're telling it from the past and
they're like that this prophecy is older
than it is yeah exactly that's and
that's exactly what seems to be going on
there now he also makes an argument that
he's talking about that you know the
very famous number of the beast yada
yada now he's saying that even back in
the day like a very very early biblical
criticism but concerning the number of
the beast you know which obviously
everybody nowadays thinks of it is 666
but he's like even back in the earliest
days of biblical criticism there were
two schools of thought on that either it
was 666 or it was six one six yeah the
ancients say that there's more than one
number yeah they refer to could be this
number that they don't know and he makes
the argument too he's like and you have
to thank to that we're using him in 666
and six one six that's Arabic numerals
he's like they would have used Greek
numerals which would have been X I see
he's like which in a way is kind of the
same like it's sort of like X and C or
like the same number but it's just in a
different spot but he's like so really
any kind of you know numerical number of
the beast or anything like that and he
also makes the argument he's like I kind
of lean toward the fact and I think he
might be right on this yeah that he's
like I don't think whoever originally
wrote revelation actually put the number
in it does but he's like I think that it
just said you know let him who has
wisdom rows calculate the number of the
beast it is the number of a man that's
period and somebody came back in later
and said what if his numbers
because he's making the point he's like
look if this is a numerological
reference to someone most people think
it's narrow but it's been [ __ ] thrown
around like everybody's six six six
numbers be Santa Christ whatever he's
like if you but if you already knew who
that referred to why would you need the
number and vice versa you wouldn't need
it so he's like so I'm kind of leaning
toward the fact that the original writer
did not put it in there yeah and he
would have would have written that
passage entirely different had he had
the number yes ed you know that whom
left understanding understand that the
number of the beast is 666 yeah yeah I
mean it would have been direct I think
he's right I think that passage there
his number is 666 was I thought it might
be a later and somebody calculated it
somebody who thought they had raised and
went and calculated it and then and then
put it in there and like I said there
was controversy over whether it was six
six six or six one six even at the time
cuz it's written in both there's an
earlier version of that book and it's
yes once like yeah he even went back to
like a theologian from I don't even
remember what central was Iranian CBS
was Iranian I'm out of inner radius yeah
where he said even then there was
controversy about what controversy about
which number it was so he's like so I'm
kind of thinking that it wasn't in there
originally so there was like kind of a
fight about what's kind of like they
should put in there it's can open the
lock and you'll know what the
combination is yeah that's it yeah
that's essentially what he was saying is
right he's not already haven't had the
combination to open the lock right he's
not arguing that there's not like
numerological references and there was
like there probably are because that was
kind of a big thing and they did that a
lot but he's like the thing is at the
time it was written they would have
known who he was who they were talking
about right so he's like so you wouldn't
need the number cuz you go oh that's
Nero or hurry I was but yeah so he's
arguing that that wasn't in there all
right so we're just about at the halfway
point so I'm gonna take a break right
now and then when we get back we'll talk
a little bit more about Revelation we
might go a little bit into Daniel and
maybe some more kind of Christmasy [ __ ]
yes you might run a little long it's
alright though yeah but that's alright
it's a Christmas special yeah run long
and you know just for being a Christmas
special I am you can't see it but I'm
drinking pumpkins bite what is this
pumpkin soup I it's something that's uh
is that spice no it's pumpkin pie
liqueur it's very good yeah it's pretty
good I got the eggnog with rum yes yeah
I don't have Roman mind doing for the
holiday season no that's that's got
something in there it's just some kind
of look or oh it's yes girl stuff
it's good though what's good yeah yeah
it's alright so I can ring it alright so
we will be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back talking about the book
of Revelation now this is my favorite
part this is my favorite part of all
this video and all this videos are
really good and super interesting and
stuff but I love this [ __ ] and I think
this is probably yeah actually actually
the [ __ ] of Babylon stuffs kind of
boring cuz most people know that that's
wrong that they're talking about this is
when it starts to get good really yeah
and honestly I mean I don't know like I
said I'm not like a you know a super
biblical the theologian or you know
expert or anything like that but I don't
think I've ever really heard anyone kind
of come to this particular conclusion
bizarro and so our Laster was doing his
homework here man yeah but this actually
seems pretty like when I when I heard it
I was like yeah that sounds
yeah so we're talking about revelation
six the very famous you know the opening
of the seals the opening of the seals in
the horsemen of the apocalypse and the
horse Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
and all that now the way he cut I don't
know if I want to lay it out the same as
he did but because it was kind of
complicated the way he laid it out but
he's like there are several allegories
taking place so yeah like layers of
allegory layers of elegance guys are a
high tech with all this with all this
[ __ ] I said games obfuscate yeah and
that's the truth and they sound rather
than yeah and they considered what they
were doing kind of like a science yeah
because astrology was a science that was
really high tech tonight so they're
being very scientific and high tech when
they talk this way yeah so I don't think
there's anything I don't like I don't
feel like this is a stretch or anything
like that because you know that these
were well-known literary devices also at
the time yeah but so okay so the first
thing we want to talk about the very
famous verse and I saw and behold a
white horse and he that sat on him had a
bow and a crown was given unto him and
he went forth conquering and to conquer
he argues that every time they refer to
a person like in this case the Conqueror
that is referring to a particular
Emperor's reign he's like so this is a
time allegory it's telling you the time
that this happened and he's like and
every time he makes a reference to an
object in this case a bow yeah that is a
seasonal allegory because it refers to a
constellation yeah and the white horse
in this case all the horses of the
Apocalypse are also
astrological or astronomical I guess you
could say because it's not necessarily
because it did have to do with stuff
they actually saw alright so he argues
that in this case the opening of the
first seal he went forth conquering and
to conquer he says this refers to the
era of Julius Caesar the first of the
dead Emperor's yeah the Beaux refers to
the constellation of Sagittarius now the
white horse I'm gonna say I'm gonna save
the horses until last okay because
that's kind of cold nothing is just that
Julius Caesar was offered a crown yeah
he was offered a crown was given a crown
yeah right yeah they turned it down he
wanted yes so they're like so it's more
than just conquer because it was a lot
of it yeah they're talking about so
they're definitely talking about the
arrow Julius Caesar the next one has the
red horse and it said and power was
given to him that sat thereon to take
peace from the earth and that they
should kill one another and it was given
unto him a great sword now he argues
that this is talking about the era of
Augustus aka Octavian that caesar
stepson right who reigned during a time
of conflicts but also one of peace and a
staff meeting yeah yeah meaning that he
could bring peace but he could also take
it away whatever he wanted to the sword
reference doesn't particularly allude to
Augustus it is probably an allusion to
the constellation Perseus so the next
one is a black horse he that sat on him
had a pair of balances in his hand you
should probably know what that refers to
I heard a voice in the midst of the four
beasts say a measure of wheat for a
penny and three measures of barley for a
penny and see thou hurt not the oil and
the wine the economic references here
are probably a reference to the next
Emperor who was Tiberius who
consolidated power and whose leadership
brought a great deal of wealth to the
Empire and the reference to the scales
of course is the constellation Libra the
next is the pale horse his name that sat
on him was death and hell followed with
him or Hades some of them say and power
was given unto them over the fourth part
of the earth to kill with sword and with
hunger and with death and with the
beasts of the earth this is a likely
reference to the next emperor who was
Caligula he bankrupted the state he
killed the wealthy he stole their money
and he presided over a famine and a
plague that took place around 30 9c e
now the reference to hell or Hades
probably a reference to the Hyades
cluster of stars in the constellation
Taurus now the 5th seal this is kind of
like this one does not have a horseman
that goes along with it this is almost
kind of like one that's like why isn't
the end of the world coming yet you know
what I mean I saw under the altar the
souls of them that were slain for the
word of God for the testimony which they
held they cried with a loud voice saying
how long O Lord holy and true dost thou
not judge and avenge our blood on them
that dwell on the earth like when is God
coming to kick ass press this guy this
guy and this guy comes and that guy
they're all bad why is this [ __ ] still
going on right that's essentially what
he's saying right now he's saying that
this reference since there's no horsemen
and stuff like that this is probably a
reference to the reign of Claudius who
actually was a very good Emperor there
was a lot of stability and all this
other stuff now he's arguing he's like
the altar reference was a little weird
it might just mean a regular altar but
he does note that there is a
constellation called ARA the altar
that's what it's called now he's like
this is a very rare constellation it's
not usually seen that far north right so
he's like so I didn't know if I wanted
to go in this direction when I saw that
but it all worked out in the end there's
no horse because Claudius was he was
limb are you're not Olimpico he had a
cerebral postural palsy he could not
ride a horse good right over that - um
he's like yeah that might have something
to do with why there's not a horseman
and then the famous uh sixth seal
opening of the sixth seal there was a
great earthquake the Sun became black as
sackcloth of hair the moon became as
blood and all this other stuff now he's
arguing that the Sun turning black he's
like that could only mean one thing and
Eclipse so what he did was he's like so
I went on NASA's website and I wanted to
see if there was an eclipse he's like
the because the way this is written
because he had the Sun turns black and
the moon sees like that's an eclipse
probably but he's like the stars of
heaven fell into earth even as a fig
tree casteth her untimely figs and the
heaven departed as a scroll in his
rolled together every mountain and
island moved to other places it's like
everyone there was all this [ __ ]
happening so he's like that's probably a
reference to the great fire witch a
reference to Nero so he's basically
saying that he's looking for an eclipse
that happened during the reign of Nero
because that is what he thinks this is
referring to so it turns out that
checking the NASA website brings up
unequipped that took place on April 30th
59 C II he's like the total eclipse
would have been a little further south
he's like but a partial eclipse would
have been visible all through Rome and
Jerusalem and everywhere many notes that
plenty of the elder also wrote about
this particular eclipse so it's kind of
you know well documented this so this is
what he's saying he says so I you can go
to this site and I guess it's still I
guess it's still around I think it's
called your sky and you can basically
put in any location at any time in
history and see what the night sky
looked like from that area so he did
that for this particular day he
discovered that all the constellations
that had turned up in the in these you
know the the scales the altar the
Perseus all of these they all appeared
on that night in the night sky in the
night sky in that particular order in
that order yes so the code and he was
also saying that the four horsemen he's
like this is really interesting at the
time of the maximum eclipse as seen from
Jerusalem four planets would have been
visible in a line in the same order that
they're laid out in the text right Mars
is the fiery red horse Jupiter is the
white horse riding out Venus is the pale
horse mercury is the black horse and
it's interesting to that where the
Eclipse happened like where you could
see it in the sky was right near the
Hyades cluster which they're calling
Hades what are you saying you know hell
followed right behind it followed this
apocalyptic Eclipse and he's also saying
too that he's like even though pretty
much every Bible translation has you
know when the sixth seal is opening it
was a great earthquake he points out
that the Greek word sighs mos he's like
earthquake is its third definition the
first definition is just any kind of
upheaval so he's like so he's arguing
that the apocalyptic event was
klipsch right not an earthquake right
and he's saying that this is an
astrological allegory about stuff that
happened the night of the Eclipse like
the way the constellations moved the way
the planets were and things of that
nature which I thought was pretty cool
and that actually sounds pretty legit
yeah now some people might wonder how
the hell could that got it if a guy
writing this how would he have access to
all that information if he's writing
about it in the past he had to have been
there to see all this happen I'm gonna
say no he doesn't have to because you
have to remember that the Romans back in
those days had computers that were
mechanical like the Antikythera device
that could tell you what was in the
night time sky on any given date in the
past or the future and that was a really
high-tech computer device that they used
because really the money in Rome was
about fortune-telling oh yeah so
probably what happened was is that he
knew through writings that sometimes in
the past what was that 58 59 see ya yeah
in 59 BCE he knew that was a bad time
and he knew that an eclipse happened
yeah so something must have been very
important so he went to his mechanical
computer and went back to that date on
which the Clips happened and then he
looked to see what's what after logical
signs are in the sky alternately someone
might have written about it at the time
at the time you ain't knows commercial
and he had someone who had seen it
should she's like I said like plenty the
Eldar for example had seen it and maybe
made mention yeah no that's no that's
another and he might have just been
using that as a source and 30 or 40
years later a guy a Roman guy could have
checked that guy's work and average that
on those computers and went back and
verified yes that did happen in the
heavens cuz this is all happening in
heaven their concept of sky is not the
same as ours what's in the sky is what's
happening in heaven yeah that's why all
these astrological signs are so
important and they really they're the
foundations of Christianity which we
like yeah the whole Greek mythology
thing I mean everyone would have been
familiar with in there was still very
much of that going on and it bled into
the early Jewish and Christian writings
I think it's all over the place yeah so
and that kind of leads me on to my next
thing too which is Revelation 12 now
this is a very interesting chapter and
Zoroaster makes the claim this is one
about the Dragon of the bird yes oh this
is good that he thinks that this is
actually the earliest or actually a
proto Jesus yeah the story foundation of
the Christian Jesus concept may come
from this yeah that's what and it sounds
pretty reasonable like I said so this
one there appeared a great wonder in
heaven a woman clothed with the Sun and
the moon under her feet and upon her
head a crown of twelve stars now he says
that the twelve stars it's possible that
it could be a reference to the
constellation cepheus but he's like it
might be a later interpolation which
just represents the twelve tribes of
Israel but he's like for sure the woman
clothed with the Sun and the moon under
her feet is probably the constellation
Andromeda so you know so this is a
pregnant woman she's you know having
childbirth pain something like that
there appeared another wonder in heaven
behold a great red dragon having seven
heads and ten horns and seven Crown's
upon his head again seven and ten same
numerological references before and he's
arguing that the red dragon is probably
the constellation Hydra and he said it
is red because he's saying that this
whole chapter is a reference to another
Eclipse that happened in 71 seee same
deal you could see it from Jerusalem and
from Rome and from Athens and he's like
there's a similar kind of thing going on
here where all of these stories are kind
of going on up in the heavens during
this Eclipse because it was like such an
apocalyptic event so he's arguing that
the Hydra constellation is coming across
the sky it's red because it's head was
kind of around where Mars was and then
there's it kind of goes on you know
brought forth the manchild stuff like
that which like I said later on would
kind of turn into the Jesus story but
he's arguing that at this point it's
basically an astrological story taking
place in the heavens there was a war in
heaven Michael and his angels fought
against the Dragon and the dragon fought
and his angels and the Great Dragon was
cast out the dragon gets casted earth
the woman was given two wings of a great
eagle serpent cast out of his mouth
water as a flood after the woman and
things of that nature so so he's saying
okay so there was an eclipse in March of
71 see now during this Eclipse the
constellation of Andromeda was situated
in such a way that her feet were
pointing toward the moon like in the
story yeah like in the story and this
was as seen from Greece now the
reference to Michael killing the dragon
he's like there are some other
references to Michael or the Archangel
Michael and stuff like that and it
almost seems like it's analogous to
Perseus or Hercules like a sibling it's
a similar kind of story so he's arguing
that the constellation Hydra is going
across the sky and then sometime during
the night the constellation Hercules
comes across the sky and metaphorically
slays the Hydra just like he did in the
story and he also says and this is
interesting too he's like you know the
whole reference to the woman being given
eagle wings and stuff like that he's
like another constellation that appeared
this night coming up after Andromeda was
Aquila which is the eagle hmm it's an
Eagle constellation he said they also
made reference to a river and he's like
another constellation that appeared that
night was arid anus or arid anis which
is the river and he's like in the and
the way it appeared in the sky made it
look as though it was falling onto the
earth type of yang so they've seen the
constellations rise and fall they're
making a story to describe to describe
the motions in the heavens right right
as if they are witnessing a heavenly
event I was heavenly story unfolding
yeah and he's saying there's also a
reference in Revelation 19 to heavenly
warrior on a white horse he's like so
that could also be a reference to
Hercules which kind of followed Jupiter
which is the white horse across the sky
on that night now he's arguing that
because whoever wrote this initially you
know had this story and stuff like that
but he's like now later Christian
writers probably layered the story of
Jesus over it yeah right so he's making
thinking that they're talking thinking
that they're talking about Jesus and
what he says about that you know he said
so this whole pursuit of Andromeda
across the sky by the Hydra and all this
and then Hercules killing the dragon
he's like they pretty much like
retconned that yeah you know the twelve
stars represent the twelve tribes of
Israel from which Christianity was born
the pregnant woman URI Andromeda became
Mary the red dragon became Herod
pursuing Mary and Jesus pregnant woman
fleeing to the wilderness which was part
of the story - that became the escape to
Egypt the dragon waging war against the
woman's offspring became Herod's
slaughtered the innocents he's making
the argument that I think dr. price goes
a lot into this too because I was find
that's really interesting that a lot of
the Christian stories are based in these
mythological and mainly astrological
tales that they've kind of taken them
they they took something that happened
in the heavens and they brought it down
to earth and personified it's called you
Hemmer ization yes it's where you take a
mythological create a person or creature
and then try to describe it in
historical ways to make it seemed like
or to explain why you believe in this
myth well we believe in this myth
because it was based on a guy who
actually existed right you know the
Greeks thought that Zeus act was was
based on a king that once existed right
and that you know Mars you know the God
of War or whatever was based upon some
ancient soldier that once lived no it
was just made up well some a person
might say well this is in the New
Testament though it written after
supposedly after the time that Jesus was
born so they must be talking about Jesus
there's a big problem with that there's
something called the end as our last
resort astor talks a bit about it's
called the primacy of Marcion
christianity the first Christian Bible
was the book of Marcio we don't have it
because the Catholic Church destroyed it
but some of the church fathers the
followers described what was in it and
what was in it was a lot of the Pauline
material which does not describe earthly
Jesus and I think one of the Gospels the
Pauline Jesus was not a Jesus really
that lived earth he was more of a
celestial Jesus he did not come from the
Old Testament God he came from the
plural the place where all the gods come
from in heaven so it could be that this
is Christian material but it's from the
Pauline era from a time when Christians
did not believe in a Jesus that was born
of woman yeah that's why they keep
saying over and over again they do he
was born he was born of it we're all
[ __ ] born yeah look some of the
Christians did not believe that Jesus
was born right so that's why that's in
there that's why the times because
they're asserting it right because
previous to that he hadn't been right he
was like you said it's the more of an
angel type of show some of these birth
narratives of Jesus that ended up in you
know in gospel stories may have been
based on marceia night type concepts of
things that were recorded that they saw
in the heavens like this prophecy right
here yeah that's what that's all it is
and another thing I should know - it's
like you know we haven't really got into
the Book of Daniel or anything like that
but the reason he got the idea to
interpret revelation in this way as an
as a historical allegory or an
astrological allegory is because it's
actually much less unusual for the Book
of Daniel to be interpreted that way and
it has been interpreted that way by many
scholars so he just found it interesting
that no one had really done revelation
the same way because you know there's
stuff in the Book of Daniel - where the
whole thing about Nebuchadnezzar and his
dream and how Daniel is like
interpreting his dreams you know and
there's the statue with the golden head
the silver body the bronze waist the
iron legs the iron and clay feet and he
points out that most biblical scholars
you know say that that statue is a
metaphor and he's like and it even kind
of says it like outright in the text the
golden head represents Babylon under
Nebuchadnezzar the silver body is
probably the next reign which was the
rate of nabonidus which was like an
inferior kind of thing it's like the
bronze waist is thought to be the
Persian Empire which took over Babylon
in 539 B seee the iron kingdom said to
crush all others that was the reign of
Alexander the Great the fact that the
feet of the statue was iron mixed with
clay meant that that Empire would soon
break into pieces which it did and so
you know I don't think that was actually
a prophecy I think it was a teaching
tool to teach the region history I think
it's all that seemed like the imagined
history like a statue standing in front
of you with a gold head in a silver
blessed breastplate and now there's you
know two legs break it off with a bunch
of little toes and it's all getting weak
we're falling apart but basically what I
do kind of feel like that's what it is
and like I said if you read those
biblical passages pretty not so much in
Revelation because revelation is kind of
obscure but the Book of Daniel I mean
sometimes it says outright the statue
with the golden head is your kingdom
Nebuchadnezzar so it's not like they're
he's trying to be sneaky or sly or
anything like that he's saying outright
that that's what it's a metaphor and and
the author is saying it's okay to look
at history this way because that's the
way Nebuchadnezzar looked at it
everything has to do with giving the
author authority yeah I'm telling you is
true because Nebuchadnezzar believed it
yeah so you should believe it too this
is what history is like a picture it
like a man standing there with a gold
head well that's this member that Old
Kingdom yeah well it's getting worse and
look now instead of one things are going
to [ __ ] going to [ __ ] sit in one big
trunk now you got two legs it's breaking
they're they're weak and then they get
weaker as they go down to the feet and
then you got ten toes there we're
falling apart yeah it does that's what
they're talking and like I said most of
the Book of Daniel that have these
allegorical stories a lot of them pretty
much say outright because most of the
allegories in it are Nebuchadnezzar's
dreams that Daniel is interpreting like
he said it's just kind of another way of
looking at history from like it is Xaro
Esther's or after he said that that
Daniel was easy he said revelation was a
little harder although parts of
Revelation like the early parts are like
the first parts of Revelation are really
good because they're very pinpoint very
precise yeah but it gets more and more
generalized and very confused as it goes
which he thinks there's at least two
authors there's one that was very
precise and another one that was a
little more sloppy that inherit this
book as he was working on it yeah it was
an edited possibly harmonized at least
once by maybe that second guy or maybe a
third or a fourth guy so there's no
talent you're not seeing the originals
right and he's arguing to that whoever
the authors of the Book of Daniel were
he's like now for a long time the
accepted scholarship was that the Book
of Daniel had Britain been written about
600 BCE but he's arguing and actually
most scholars nowadays say it was
probably written more like 150 BCE yeah
old right so it's not as not really not
as old as as they first thought and you
have to think too that the authors of
Daniel you know they were writing about
a lot of this stuff from probably a
while later yeah because he says there's
a lot of like references to like the
Seleucid Empire and things like that
he's like they get that mostly right but
he's like whoever wrote Daniel kept
mixing up a bunch of them Babylonian and
Persian kings yeah so he's like so it
must have been a while or he didn't
really have access to that knowledge
he's like cuz he keeps messing up you
know at one point like he keeps messing
up like he calls serous the Great who
was the one that took over Babylon the
Persian king that's Cobre family he he's
calling to rious the mead he's like you
know Jiraiya's there were three devices
I believe but you know that was later on
it's like it wasn't the same guy well
part of these like and those guys were
famous you think you think you think you
would know part of the reason why the
town this story is because they didn't
have standardized calendars right each
little civilization had its own calendar
and it made sense it was like the third
the third year of the rule of you know
negativity Nezzer ii yeah there's so
much in seco he didn't know okay well
what was what was the elusive Empire
doing in in the third year of [ __ ]
bubbeleh there was no you couldn't just
say back in 1972 you know there wasn't a
universally accepted calendar right so
history was extremely hard to imagine in
ancient times especially when you didn't
have an internet and there was no
centralized libraries to speak of pot in
your area maybe in another area there
may event yeah so you may have had two
or three different books cuz the book
was expensive you may have had two or
three different books that were from
unrelated sources and you weren't sure
what happened what happened when like I
live first you know Werth was our the
Egyptian where are the Egyptians older
than the Aleutians so you know what
Seleucids yeah you don't know so you
don't know you know you can't put
anything any kind of order using those
old books and like I said I think that's
why they make so many references to you
know during the Arab jewel yeah they're
an era of narrow or whatever because you
know there's no there's no precision and
how they live in timekeeping so the
author of Daniel is just saying well
Nebuchadnezzar just imagines it like a
man standing there with a gold head yeah
and a gift becomes yeah and those are
pretty much and like I said they pretty
much say in the text that they're
referring to specific Kingdom Kingdom so
it's a history lesson so yeah it's
basically what it is yeah so you know so
it doesn't seem it's not a super stretch
to say that the book of Revelation was
written in the same way is there in a
prophetic style but it's written by
people that lived through it through it
or lived you know later on right and
then we're using older sources because
he does say that one of the books in
Revelation is probably referring to the
eruption of Vesuvius yeah you got that
like yeah well there's not like a I mean
it's pretty obvious in that chapter that
that's what he's talking but it's
obviously a volcano eruption yeah he's
on the stone into the ocean and and that
destroy yeah the water getting bitter
yeah that that's the yeah and he's
saying that he's not saying that the guy
that wrote that particular chapter was
necessarily alive when Vesuvius erupted
but he's like well the thing is plenty
the younger on about busy because he was
there and every day there was some of
the other died during that he died into
but his son survived his son survived
and he wrote a book about the eruption
of Mount Vesuvius and it was evidently a
best-seller and the some of the
descriptions in yeah and in Revelations
match the descriptions that were given
in that book so that means that the
author did not see Mount Vesuvius he
just described Mount Vesuvius based on
what he read read of someone he's a
younger and he's describing it as an
angel throwing a stone into the ocean
and putrifying the the white water are
in yeah yeah yeah destroyed a certain
amount of the fleet and it's basically
and it's funny because you can really
see there's also a lot of mentions of
plagues yeah that's and lots of mists
well there's probably a lot of places
but the thing is and you can really see
there kind of thread even coming up to
the modern day with like all these kind
of apocalyptic some sort of like
Christian offshoots that are very
apocalyptic and they're always waiting
for and like I said a lot of them
interpret Revelation as something that's
going to happen so they're they're doing
the same thing essentially that people
back then we're doing they're looking at
disasters and being like the world's
turning to [ __ ] yes all gonna end
there's volcanoes and you know and
eclipses and all this other kind of
civilization and right so it's the same
kind of thinking as now as people like
oh there's Wars and this and that the
other thing but it's like you know as
human history has shown that [ __ ]
happens all the time always happening
somewhere yeah so you know to just
pinpoint one thing though there's more
wars there's more sickness now than
there was remember apocalyptic thinking
from the age of Ronald Reagan well you
think that the earth would be a gone by
now well yes seem like you know I guess
that sells books for them and stuff like
that cuz we did that whole show that one
show about doomsday predictions and
something like that and I always kind of
just you know whatever the earth will be
okay yeah
yeah you may not be here but there
you'll just keep on truckin cuz that's
what it does so since this is our
Christmas special and we're coming up to
the end of it yeah what do you like the
most about Christmas [ __ ] presents
yeah yeah they are good presents
then just hanging out you know I can
eggnog and listening to music and I got
a ham I got a boneless ham to cook we do
yes yeah yeah we are gonna show you up
and everything you know what sucks the
only thing that sucks about Christmas
and this is sucked since I was a child
because I am from Florida originally I
was born here and it doesn't snow here
you guys like hardly ever I like I think
it's snowed here a couple times but it's
not even like snows no it's just like oh
look a flake and then it melts yeah it's
no ten years ago yeah something like
that but it's an it stick on the ground
it's not like real snow so I always used
to watch like Christmas specials and
Christmas movies and stuff like that
when I was little and I'd look at all
these people and they all warm in the
house and they had hot chocolate then a
fire going in the fireplace and of like
you guys suck yeah any of it it's like
90 degrees that try they see you right
yes that's what we used to do I mean
because a few times like every now and
then we'll get lucky and it'll be cold
on Christmas Day but it hardly ever is
yeah like it's it's rare that it's like
90 degrees but it's usually like in the
70s yeah wish I guess some people are
alike which you're winding journey like
I'm from [ __ ] Minnesota and it's
freezing I'm freezing my testicles off
up here but you know what I mean but
there was always just like a romance
about it yet I never got to participate
I got to do it yeah well you got to do
it but you know I never got to
participate in everything I always lived
here you're not missing that's really
the same old same old thing I didn't so
seriously I did not see snow until I was
22 years old
isn't that funny I know it's awful but
yeah I always wanted it to snow around
Christmastime and I never got to see
that okay let's shut it down this is uh
this show was an introduction to
Zoroaster Zoroaster the guys at [ __ ]
genius we're gonna put links and yeah
I'll put a link to his yeah you know
this is just just an introduction to his
work he's got a vast body of work we
can't talk about it all within an hour
so go check it out for yourself you're
gonna like it yeah it was super fun and
I hope you guys enjoyed this sort of
Christmas special a special it was kind
of special on be sure to check out our
patreon page or if you'd rather not do
that then go to our blog which you know
what it is show us some love on PayPal
with a one-time donation if you would
also check out our latest movie review
which was the frighteners check out my
book the faceless villain which is now
out in print ebook and audiobook and if
you wanted a free code it should be just
a few days I will get those sent out
because like I said I have to wait for
audible to email them to make and if
that'll do it for this episode of 13
o'clock happy holidays
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you